le 6 janvier 2021 l'impensable se
produit à washington
nous n'abandonnerons jamais nous ne
céderons jamais cela n'arrivera pas on
ne sait pas quand il ya un vol
nous allons descendre au capitole
ne digérant pas sa défaite aux urnes
donald trump attise la foule de
sympathisants dans five si vous ne vous
battez pas comme des diables vous
perdrez votre pays
des manifestants survoltés lancent
l'assaut
la force du nombre l'emportent
le capitole et envahi peu après 14h
rassemblés dans l'hémicycle pour
certifier le vote présidentiel
les élus prennent la fuite où se cache
mike pence le vice-président est escorté
six heures de violences un défi
sécuritaire impossible dans le delaware
joe biden den ans l'insurrection te sort
notre démocratie vit en ce moment une
agression sans précédent qui ne
ressemble à rien de ce que nous avons vu
dans les temps modernes
c'est le plus grand assaut depuis que
l'armée britannique a détruit le
bâtiment durant la guerre de 1812
plusieurs heures après l'assaut trempe
demande aux assaillants de rentrer chez
eux en maintenant que l'élection a été
volée du raft grand meneur will of peace
la garde nationale fini par arriver ce
n'est qu'aux premières heures du 7
janvier fait la victoire de joe biden
sera officialisée
[Applaudissements]
140 policiers sont blessés cinq
personnes sont mortes plus de 700
personnes sont inculpées pour leur
participation à l'attack la démocratie
américaine est mise à l'épreuve le
spectre de l'assaut du capital risque de
peser sur les prochaines élections à
commencer par celles de mi mandat à
l'automne ici est une cravate radio
canada montréal